[Music]
as you can tell by the title itself in
this video I'm wearing in the season 8
episode 3 league script I have to warn
you that this script does matter the
season 8 outline I'd received and share
with you as well as with all the season
8 leaked photos so before we continue
keeping in mind that this might be an
actual season 8 script so let's just
jump in it first we have this scene from
interval after the battle is over
it says Jamie's walking over nation snow
covered ground Winterfell is still
burning lifeless bodies everywhere
I got a stop right there to say that
this match is for the leaked outline
there it says that Winterfell is on fire
caused by all the fire Arabs dead living
used to kill White's
Winterfell being on fire has also been
confirmed by a bunch of leaked photos
from season 8 Winterfell set the script
continues for Jaime approaching Jon in
Tyrion in case you haven't seen the
leaked plot I shared a couple of months
ago jamie has in this very same episode
just arrived at Winterfell and not only
that but he's arrived at the last moment
in the living side and Winterfell used
all two forces the head and then what's
left of them stood no chance to emerge
victorious at at moment two hooded men
enter the gates of Winterfell out
flanking the army of the Dead these two
hooded men turned out to be Jaime and
Bronn followed by the Lannister Fratelli
army led by Admiral E basically the
first two episodes of season 8 Jimmy
went river on Tralee the Lancer forces
that were sent to the Riverlands to
ensure peace and while he was added he
probably told ed more about the danger
that his nieces and nephews are facing a
new tally likely rarely deliver Lance
and joined Jaime on his march north the
Riverlands include the freight soldiers
as well who now that their Lords have
been killed him most likely switched
allegiance to Edmund anyways let's
continue with the script it says turn
regards Jaime but not speak
James says since we arrived at the right
time we have one did we get him John
glance inside Jamie turn answers to
Jaime with the words that one the night
King wasn't here the night King wasn't
here where then Jaime asks in the far
south John replies that was approaches
this sketches Jaime by surprise
south Jaime asks and continues with what
about Danny and heard Tyrion cuts Jaime
often replies to him with bran says Nat
King flew his dragon to Dorne he's
trying to form a new army bigger army
then he went there with her dragons
she'll stop him
that was notices jon is worried for
Danny how does brain know all that Jaime
questions but before Tyrion could reply
jamie has another question regarding the
night king how does he have a dragon
since Tyrion would need an entire
episode just to explain to Jamie that
the kid he tried to kill some years
is now the three-eyed Raven who can find
out anything that's happened or is
happening as well as to explain how the
night king has the dragon theorem simply
says it's complicated
double steps in front of Jamie and joins
their conversation by asking I beg your
pardon sir Jamie but where's the rest of
queen services forces this cannot be all
I believe we've heard urines been
sailing north with the Ironborn the
Lannisters in the golden company they
should have arrived by this time hell
they should have arrived before the
battle even started in episode 3 at a
huge meeting and Winterfell bran shared
his vision about urine and golden
companies sailing towards north which he
says they're coming to their aid
animated Jaime replies to Davos way this
is all you will get I'm afraid you see
our dear sister does not plan to help us
win this war Cersei will rather use
urine in the gun company to win the rest
of the kingdoms fell we are protecting
north she told me herself before I
finally left her Turner looks to John
John smirks nods looks at the floor
shakes his head and begins looking at
Davos that was glance at tyrion tyrion
shakes his head what's going on here is
basically all three of them knowing
brains visions are true he's so you're
sailing north with all the might he
inserts he have now Jaime forms them
that Circe does not actually plan to
help them which means Joan is coming to
destroy what little their armies left by
brain being that we are Raven people
think that he knows everything that's
happened or is happening which simply is
not sure to explain it better let's take
a look on how the actor who plays brain
stark himself explained exactly how his
powers work on Game of Thrones the way
brains power works at the moment is that
he's basically got a Kindle library of
the whole history of the universe he
says he just has not read every book yet
and the old three-eyed Raven has set in
that tree for a thousand years and read
through every piece of history and has
accessed it all he continues with but
for now he needs people to tell him what
they want him to see that's exactly why
bran had taught John is a bastard after
witnessing his birth until he saw John's
parents being married in a secret
ceremony some told him to check out this
happen he accessed it and confirmed it
he does not know everything but he can
go and check it out and I'm aware that
the show will explain it next season
because it has many people confused
basically what happens in this case is
that branch so you're sailing with his
surcease armies north and by hearing
that Cersei promised to send help he
assumes they're coming to the north side
however no one told Brad to go back and
check out services plans that she
revealed to Jaime and discuss with urine
and the leader of the golden company no
one told bran to check if they are
really coming to the north side anyways
the script continiously that was rushing
to the top of castles walls that was
look south from the bedroom
toward South your Anna Peter Cetera born
Delaney serves in the golden company led
by Harry youren is smiling his lips are
pale blue you're an attacking Winterfell
was the battle between the living in the
dead dance to kill what's left for the
victorious parties coming as a huge
surprise but at the same time it's also
been kind of confirmed by the leaked
photos this leaked photo that was taken
on Winterfell said we can see the dead
Ironborn that would be on schedule T's
in his battle at Winterfell does seem to
be confirming yet another major event of
the final season
here's Strickland the one who attacks
Winterfell the turn is the leader of the
golden company a few months after I had
her saved the season 8 outlined Game of
Thrones cast in the role of her
Strickland for season 8 what's happening
in this part of the script is that urine
which serves his forces and the gun
company attacks Winterfell after they've
been weakened by the night king's army
it says you're only smiling and his lips
are pale blue this is something a book
readers know about but the show viewers
probably don't basically in the books
Turner's lips are pale blue because he
drinks shade of the evening which is a
blue wine shade of the evening is
heavily used by the Warlocks of Qarth
whose lips have turned blue by its
extended use anyway Stern waited for the
battle between the living and the dead
to end they are here on services orders
to kill what's left of the winning army
if you haven't seen the leaf plot of
this episode that has shared a couple of
months ago in short this battle will not
end up good for Jon in the company
what's left of Jon and Dana's armies for
the support of Jamie and then your
armies will give a fight but John will
eventually decide to end it by
surrendering and offering himself as a
hostage in exchange for a battle to be
stopped an additional casualties avoided
there's even a leaked photo of John
being taken hostage looking as landing
supporting this leak even more
additionally this scene will take place
in episode 4 as the director that
episode was seen on set that's just one
episode after the huge battle from
intervals supporting this leak of urine
taking John a hostage even more let me
also point out that the side matching
will act out line and it leaked photos
these scripts also seem to match the
episode 5 leaked script as well in which
you're in Cersei meet and discuss their
marriage let's take a quick look at
those leak threats
it says sir senior and are having a
conversation in the throne room they are
alone Cersei sits on the Iron Throne and
urine stains before her urine says
throughout my life I've experienced many
dangers a child are shy and sail the
smoking sea above the smoking ruins of
Valyria
the most recent experience was more
dangerous than all the previous ones
combined the war is won I want what's
been promised to me
Cersei replies the war is not one you
might abroad huge casualties the Dragon
Queen and her pet no turn but you're
interrupts certain states what's left if
anything is left of that
does not represent a threat to the crown
anymore the worst one Cersei replies but
it's not every single soldier Union the
gun company slew is now part of the army
of the Dead the 19th army grows stronger
day by day I promise to give him my hand
the Devi emerged victorious and the
throne is safe
did I not whatever serves his spoken
word young grows more and more angry but
let's stop here for a moment so urine
has allegedly defeated Jon Snow and any
Targaryen he claims his one a more
inserts he supports this claim by
praising his accomplishment of defeating
the quoting gen Queen her pet owner long
story short what this leaked script
seems to be claiming is that urine
instead of bringing the gun company to
King's Landing has actually brought them
to the north or upon the surprise detect
John and Dana's forces at Winterfell and
have allegedly brought massive
casualties to them the following rager
soldiers would be those under US command
or in another words here on schedule T's
the craziest thing about a slick script
is that it could be true and might have
even been foreshadowed in the previous
season behind flee you own disease you
can defeat the invaders and ease your
promise that with his help she could
defeat invaders in the east and
retainers in the north and south ural
already delivered one of his promises by
defeating her and the sand snakes and it
seems that he might have fill other
parts of it as well however this meeting
between the two in turn room will not
end up good for one of them like script
of episode 5 continues by saying young
comes a bit closer to Cersei and says
I'm not your stupid brother you can't
manipulate me we had a deal to marry
once the war against the crown Schrader
is won I want that more I only want
what's been promised to me
Cersei looks annoyed she takes a deep
breath and before she could answer even
reps it sends about her pale white
throat and starts choking the light from
her your own cells versus your monster
friend to protect you now huh or your
boyfriend brother
Cersei tries to fight but can do much
Cersei tries to talk but is not able to
do so with your sands choking her
yearned and says perhaps I don't need to
marry a troll all I have to do is kill
you and take the throne for myself
searches somehow manages to whisper the
golden company will kill you your smile
sendsteps choking Cersei he asks what
will the golden company do huge laughter
from urine follows but only for a few
seconds yearned and suddenly appears to
be anger again yearned and says you
think the golden company would stand
against me I'm the one who signed the
contract with them I'm the one who
brought them here and I'm the one who
led them into battles they're loyal to
me not you
matter of fact home as Harry already
suggested me to overthrow you you have
no soldiers
no gold your no Queen before Cersei
could reply to that Qyburn enters the
throne room your own glance ascetic
crowns maester who nods to his Queen
Cersei then goes on to say thank you for
all your help your great joy
but as of now our legions is over with
Cersei nods back to Qyburn the scene and
switches to the streets of King's
Landing where people are spreading panic
regarding nat king and his army the most
intriguing part of the script is its
ending what do Qyburn answers is not
Smee this cabin perhaps nodding to
Cersei that the mountain is ready to
kill the urine on her command or is he
perhaps nodding to her that the
pyromancers are ready to initiate the
world fire attack whatever it is Cersei
nods back to it given it the green light
so whatever it might be it's going down
fortunately we don't need to wait for
the final season to find out what's
going on here because season 8 outline
reveals it as well let's take a look at
this particular part of the leaked
outline that matches perfectly with this
episode five legs ripped it says the
next scene takes place in red keep
you don't want Cersei to fulfill her
promise he wants a very nurse says that
he fulfill is part of destroying her
enemies it's time for her to fulfill her
part Cersei refuses thanks yearn for all
the support he provided and breaks their
allegiance Circe reveals to urine that
the golden company had broken a contract
no longer fighting for her nor him
Cersei states that as of now her only
Ally is wildfire Cersei has earned
killed by the mountain urine might meet
his end later on in the season but he
will definitely be a huge problem for
John and Danny in the first episodes
they're here guys allegedly script for
the third episode of the final season
the script does may treat many leaked
photos as velvety alleged leaked outline
of the final season only this script is
far more detailed which it should be
since it's a script and not an outline
we've actually received two more scripts
for this episode so let me know if you'd
like me to share them as well and as
always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see in the next one peace
[Music]